جو يندفع فقط فيما يتعلق
بالأشهر المقبلة ، ما هي الحرب التي تستمر في
الظهور
بشكل جيد ، سنرى بعض التغييرات
في البيئة بالتأكيد أه أندرسون
لكن هذا يؤثر على كلا الجانبين وأنا
أتحدث عن الطقس
تستمر أوكرانيا في توليد الزخم
هناك محاولة من قبل روسيا
لدمج جنود حشد ، والتي
رأيناها من خلال التقارير الداخلية الروسية ،
هناك عدد أكبر من الأشخاص الذين يهربون
من البلاد أكثر من الأشخاص الذين ينتقلون
ويسيرون إلى مراكز التعبئة ،
وحتى إذا قاموا بنقل بعض هؤلاء إلى
الجنود الروس إلى الخطوط الأمامية
سوف ينضمون إلى الوحدات
التي استنزفت معنوياتهم المنخفضة
بالفعل ولم يحققوا أي نجاح في
ساحة المعركة ، لذلك سنشهد
زخمًا متزايدًا من قبل القوات الأوكرانية ،
وستشهد المزيد من الهزائم
في ساحة المعركة من قبل  القوات الروسية
ولسوء الحظ من المحتمل
أن نرى المزيد منذ
24 فبراير حيث قال بيتر إن المزيد من
الضربات بالمدفعية والصاروخية ضد المدنيين
أهداف ليان والمزيد من الأنشطة الإجرامية
التي تضع روسيا والسيد بوتين
في جانب يجب إحضاره
قبل لاهاي ،
كان هذا عادةً مهمًا لأن
هذا الجسر يربط كل شيء هنا ، لذا
دعونا نلقي نظرة على الخريطة هذه هي
المنطقة السفلية من  شبه جزيرة القرم هنا
هي بالفعل أراضي روسية
والجسر موجود داخل هذه الدائرة
هنا في بلدة الكنائس هناك ،
لذا فإن هذا الجسر هو حقًا عمل
هندسي رائع ولهذا السبب
لأنه يربط روسيا بشبه جزيرة القرم ثم
يدخل  تسمح أوكرانيا للأشخاص
بالذهاب إلى أوكرانيا مما يجعل الأمر أفضل بكثير
بالنسبة
للروس لنقل منتجاتهم.
هذا سيرى بوتين
هذا على أنه هجوم مباشر عليه وعلى
حكومته ، حسنًا ، نعم لأنه في عام
2018 فتح بالفعل هذا الجسر الذي هو
عليه.  التوجّه إلى الجسر لقيادة هذه
الشاحنة على هذا الجسر
والسبب في قيامه بذلك هو أنه كان فخورًا جدًا
بهذا الجسر
وبعلاقاته التي تمكن من منح
روسيا إلى شبه جزيرة القرم بشكل أساسي وهي
ضم شبه جزيرة القرم بشكل حقيقي.
بضم شبه جزيرة القرم فعليًا إلى روسيا ، ولهذا السبب
فعل ذلك ،
رأينا روسيا تنتقم على ما يبدو ،
وهل تتوقع المزيد من
الهجمات على المناطق المدنية في أعقاب
هذا تمامًا ولن يكون الأمر مجرد
zelp arija zapparisha هنا ،
مدينة zapparija هي في الواقع مدينة zapparija  في
أيدي الأوكرانيين ، يقع جزء من مقاطعة
زوبا ريجيا في أيدي الروس
الآن بالطبع بالطبع محطة الطاقة النووية
هنا يمكننا أن نتوقع أن يهاجم الروس على
طول هذه الجبهة ويحتمل
أن يحاولوا القيام بأشياء في هذه المنطقة
بالإضافة إلى الأوكرانيين  دخلت في
الشمال الشرقي وحتى من الممكن أن يحدث ذلك عن بعد ولكن
حتى حول كييف هناك احتمال
لحدوث شيء من هذا القبيل